what is this about this is really
important because in some ways this is
kind of the heart of the course you need
to understand you need to understand it
now at the beginning there's the idea of
the zone what it means to cultivate your
ability to think in mathematically
abstract terms is to be able to do this
how this is not original to me I have
this explained to me by a really
excellent university lecturer and I'd
love you to write it down it is to think
deeply about simple things something
deeply about simple things here's what I
need okay
we're used to seeing you know problems
that start simple and then they get more
complicated and we are used to thinking
of more complicated things as harder
classic example if I said to you this is
you have to understand if I said to you
okay
what's um what's 1 plus 1 we can manage
that
that's ok you're like 1 plus 1/2 I can
manage that - right this is slightly
more complicated because you know and
this purpose 7 point in time he knew
what numbers were but you didn't know
what fractions or how to work with them
but I can keep on making these more
complex I could say well what about this
won't this be equal to now you can still
do it I might take a bit more time what
if I kept on going like you know how do
my series before right so I take a
simple idea and I just make it more
complicated I'll make it harder or I'll
give you another one
what's the first word that comes to mind
either five or Pythagoras private ballot
okay I guess yeah I can work that out
but I can make this harder I could do
something like this
I know I know I still do it but it's
more complex so it's hard right
I want to or not okay now here's the ID
here's what this is about
the hardest things in maths are not as
they get more complicated the hardest
things are when they get simpler give me
a tip this is the simplest geometric
shape that exists you might disagree
with that but actually there's a big
hundreds of pages long that make proof
for why it is it's cold and you should
be son you can write this down and look
nothing up it's called that Poincare
conjecture French guy okay
this was one of those difficult gnarly
knotty unsolved problems of the 20th
century right to prove that a circle is
the simplest shape you're like what's so
hot about it it's such a simple shape
well what happens when you think about
me this is how many dimensions is this
picture that I've drawn it's two
dimensions right what would it look like
if it was in three dimensions I'll try
this looked at ionosphere okay right
same shape more dimensions it's still
the simplest kind of shape that exists
in three dimensions what a
four-dimensional sphere look like okay
now they're having trouble long as we
don't leave in four dimensions but the
Poincare conjecture says no matter what
number of dimensions you throw at it
four five six 27 if you're interested in
the string theory it's still the
simplest shape it's a simple thing but
if you think deeply about it they're a
profound difficult problem in it there
are other things right like you know
they are the distance that defines this
is the diameter
right but then of course there's the
other distance which is a point to this
not the radius but the circumference
right okay but we all know what the
relationship between the circumference
of a circle and its diameter is right
what's the relationship it's if we call
it PI it's a number and you can recite
what the number it is right but it's a
it's strange number
it's a weird number it breaks all the
rules that other numbers follow like
it's a simple thing but strange things
emerge from a when you think deeply in
it you don't just say oh it's a circle
of cool don't just do that think deep
for that now here's how you do it let me
give you two guides I had a big diamond
this is what you want to keep with you
and refer back to you everyone's game
for how to do this because you're not
used to it number one you want to say
why is this the case why is it true that
this number is so unusual okay and then
you might come up with an answer or some
kind and then after you get an answer to
that you need to ask this question well
why is that true all right and you know
you know they were children if any of
you have young heads up younger siblings
any family yeah how old any any like
four or five four or five yeah okay so
you guys will know right they hit the
spot and maybe you remember this
interesting wings up hold it now where
they they'll just follow you around and
they'll be like hey hey why why this why
that right and you're like man you're so
annoying I've got things to do
I've got I've got you know YouTube music
videos to watch it I don't want to
answer questions okay but they're very
important they valuable right why is the
sky blue your noise wise guys because
because it's it's it reflects light in
some way why is my true friend
you get my point
ask it and don't stop
we're used to either not asking or after
a little while sort of shoving up the
boys showerhead try to make our little
siblings be quiet
but don't need to listen to again okay
and pursue the answers here's your first
technique for thinking deeply about
simple things the other thing is what if
okay now there's lots of things which
people will tell you you cannot do okay
you cannot do this you cannot do that
and so it's like well what would happen
if that happens but you don't know and
you will never know but in maths you can
always know right what if you've got
numbers right numbers like Sam here we
were over here what is this equal to
actually no to the action of how do you
work it out it's a square root of 103
points you squared right plus 4.8 squid
and you can chuck that in the calculator
I should really brave you can try and
doing you add I just made the numbers so
I assume they're pretty bad numbers okay
so now if you go right that's gonna be a
nice number what happens if this number
underneath here is not positive but
negative now some people said you can't
do that right yeah you can't you can't
take a like what what number what number
can you say that's equal to that will
give you back a negative number when you
square it yeah one two three fractions
negative notice doesn't work you can't
do it but what if you could write what
if you took a number like that and you
gave it a name and then saw what
happened right now we call these
imagining numbers and then you put them
together with other numbers the numbers
you want familiar with like like 2 and
we call these the complex numbers right
now it just so happens but it took
decades used to come out it just so
happens that imaginary numbers and
complex them is despite the name they're
just as real as any others and they
follow the same kinds of math
medical rules but it came from some
crazy guy saying well stuff for you guys
you said you can't do it
what if you can now this is a sideman
somebody picked up there are some there
are some inconsistencies that come out
when you think about this thing right
for instance one of the lines in my
proof one of the early ones was this and
then we thought what was on the right
hand side you remember this right now
people said you can't do this you can't
do it you can't just we sort of whipped
them around like they were normal
numbers and you can't cuz they're not
normal numbers they go on forever and
they're weird and crazy don't follow the
rules but what if they did right and
then these kinds of things emerge right
these two questions or are these two
sets of questions right they would guide
you through thinking deeply about simple
things okay and that's what's going to
help you cultivate your ability to think
about mathematically outside okay